well if anyone out there is looking for
a gift to get their child or manchild I
think I've found it The Legend of Zelda
a link between worlds to Legend of Zelda
a link between worlds is a new Zelda
game for the 3ds but it's not a
third-person 3d ish Selda game like
we've had since Ocarina of Time except
Phantom Hourglass and things like that
this is an overhead Zelda game and all I
heard about it was if it's not a sequel
to a Link to the Past
it's a Zelda game that's in the same
style as a Link to the Past for the sake
of nostalgia bomb either way I was like
I'm getting this game no matter what I
got it and I'm happy yeah if you play
the Link to the Past you're gonna be
right at home with this game is the same
style it's the same world set up it does
have enough differences to make it its
own game now the thing that irritated me
at first was the Zelda theme wasn't the
Zelda theme it was like this really
subtle nice town music version of the
Zelda theme and I was like it is gonna
be the way it is the entire game but the
more you progress your quest the more
the Zelda theme plays until it's just
full-blown dinner don't under the door
just like yeah Master Sword [ __ ]
and you're on your zelda quest feel like
a child again is like a Link to the Past
there are some impressively new elements
in it first of all the big thing in this
game is that link in phase into the wall
and become a painting and you walk along
the wall to get to certain things in
areas when I first saw that I was like
that might just be some wonky mechanic
they're using for the sake of having a
new mechanic so they have an excuse to
make a new Zelda game that's like a Link
to the Past but no it's actually really
cool good well put together
well-thought-out mechanic and a Zelda
game is one of those mechanics I always
forget about because it's just it's a
new mechanic in a Zelda game so I see
areas I'm like I don't know how to go
yeah I can phase into the wall mmm go
get the item and it would all work out
for me another thing this to me is the
biggest thing in the entire game is that
every Zelda game had its dungeons and
you sequentially beat them in a certain
order you beat one and then you go to
two and then you go to three unless you
play a Link to the Past in which case
you go and Forge the sword and get all
the items and you go back to level two
with your beefed out master sword you
just waste that boss because we all did
that but the point is you do beat the
dungeons in the order that the game
intends you to beat them this one is
like here are all the dungeons go
wherever you want beat them in any order
yeah you get the special items from this
guy who rents them to you
ooh 450 rupees or you can buy them for a
few hundred you rent them and then if
you die he'll take them back and have to
re rent them but the fact is friends I
never died in this game I don't know
what game over looks like I'll say that
the game is a bit easy because it plays
like a Link to the Past and my friends
that is my childhood if you rent all the
items for 50 rupees you're out a few
hundred and by the time you die you have
made a few thousand so you just rent it
again anyway it really behooves you just
to get everything that's actually really
cool my friend and I beat the dungeons
in a different order so I had different
items at different phases in the game
I had my master sword beefed out before
he did he had this before I did and if
there's a nostalgic type I know alright
here it is I advocate this game on the
premise that I believe I truly believe
is a good standalone game that you can
get if you've never played a Link to the
Past and you play it you're like that
was fun for nothing else if you have a
friend who's like the Zelda games are so
long and those dungeons oh my god with
the water levels the water levels I'm
not playing Zelda you can get them a
link between worlds and be like this is
a bit shorter a bit easier to play it
and they'll like it for the rest of us
out there if you have played a Link to
the Past if you are attached to a Link
to the Past
I'm telling you friends this game at a
point estelle jump it's like that and it
is excellent and of course you don't
just beat the game you got to find all
the secrets get all the heart container
pieces there are a couple of heart
container pieces I'm like I'm not
getting those like because I suck at
wonky mechanic baseball games and that
race is stupid that's why that's simply
why the reason I like a Link to the Past
and a link between worlds is that it's
the pacing a link between worlds has
more dialogue more story based
conversations than a Link to the Past AB
but in the end the pacing is really
tight you talk to a couple people you go
on your adventure here it is now you're
in the adventure you're in the Zelda
game go nuts go crazy have fun I will
say in terms of items in the game this
game is lacking usually in Zelda games
you like look at this slew of new [ __ ]
except for the boomerang because I'll
have that but look at this fluid stuff
it's awesome I haven't seen that and
that's cool how that works that's cool
how that works the Link to the Past had
a lot more items in the game where's a
third waken bombo's I would love that
this game doesn't have stuff like that I
wish it had more extra items if you're
used to Ocarina of Time and Skyward
Sword you'll be like these dungeons are
pretty simple so are the bosses who are
the caretakers of the dungeons but it
would make sense if it's an easy dungeon
it's gonna have an easy boss but I still
haven't beaten that stupid baseball
minigame so there is that in the end the
Legend of Zelda a link between worlds
it's a really good Zelda game it's
really fun to play I think anybody can
pick this game up let it be like I had a
lot of fun with that game objectively if
I'd never played a Link to the Past I
would tell you it's a great game you
should pick it up it's fine but since I
made friends I'm just telling you the
Legend of Zelda a link between worlds is
awesome tacular
I love dis - I love Zelda when they come
together is lock peas and carrots again
- The Legend of Zelda a link between
worlds have you played won't you think
about it if you haven't what's your
favorite Zelda game and if you have a
favorite Zelda game why haven't you
played a link between worlds whatever
your thoughts comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more